If we dumped a recording Go Pro
into a container of liquid nitrogen
how long do you think it would keep recording
before it freezes up and shuts down.
I just got back from the store where i picked up a couple of go pros
I got the Hero 5 Black as well as the Hero 5 Session
This one cost me about $400 And if it survives this torture trail Im gonna give it to one of you
This one here is the Hero 5 Black
It records 12 megapixles and also shoots in 4K
Another cool feature is its got a LCD screen on the back so you can actually see what your recording as you do it.
Thats a nice feature to have
This one here is the new Hero 5 Sesssion
Shoots in 10 Megapixels and 5K
Which my old one only shoots in 1080
And this one has a built stabilizer as well so as your hand holding it
it helps balance out some of the footage.
So might be a good idea to start off with my older Go Pro
to see if this is even a viable idea
Because I don't want to waste new technology unnecessarily
We just filled up our container with liquid nitrogen
You can see this thing is extremely frosty and ready to go
So lets throw this thing in the tongs, get it recording
Then give it its cryogenic bath that its destine to take
So We've got this set up on blue tooth
right now I'm actually doing a screen record of what we're seing here on the Go Pro
That way if this Freezes up, we'll still the backup footage on my cellphone
Hey Guys, ready to go?
Here are the tongss,
And lets just go ahead and dip this in for maybe like 5 seconds  and see if it survives
Okay, we are confirmed recording
Its time to dip.
And apparently it looks like its still recording
And over here you can see, Yup we're stilling getting the Bluetooth feed.
So thats really cool.
Oh thats really cool, we got a
Phone with in a Phone with in a phone with in a phone
Thats Phoneception
So very cool, Our go pro survived the first 5 seconds
I didn't really have and doubt that it would because it didn't really cool down to much
So this time lets push the boundary, lets fully submerge it and just leave it in there until the nitrogen cools it down completely
Im a little bit nervous about this one because we might loose the footage
but thats a risk im willing to take
There we go.
It is fully submerged and all you can see now is this little red flashing light at the bottom of the container.
Now the reason its bubbling so profusely is because the Hero is cooling down
And releasing all that heat
As the nitrogen bubbles start to flatten out that means our hero session will of cooled down completely
And if you look over here at the camera
this is the view that our cameras haivng right now
and its still recording
The red light's still flashing. We're into it about 25 seconds now
And its still going
That red light
Oh there it goes! Camera low battery
So we just got a low battery warning
I no longer see the red light flashing but i do see
its still recording through the Bluetooth feed
But this is actually really impressive, i didnt expect it to go this long
We just got like a triple flash there, the camera just turned off.
I cant tell if the camera turned its self off just because it had a low battery warning
Or it was the nitrogen that froze it solid
That was maybe really bad timing and i probably should of charged this before hand
But based on these results I think i am willing to experiment  with the new cameras and put them through
the same experiments and see what kind of results we get with them
Im really curious to know if we saved the footage or not.
Haha.
Woooow
It is Suuuper cold
But you know what, it looks in great shape, ohh it just frostbit me
Imma set it there, woah the back plate just came off
Hey, ever wondered whats inside a go pro?
I gotta put that down tho because its like frost biting my fingertips
That is really really cold guys
Its actually so cold that its condensing the moisture out of the air
That we're getting frost build up all around and if I breathe on
it we can just accelerate that effect
and that is how you get yourself a
custom white GoPro okay so we got the
hero five session we got it hooked up to
my phone and we got our nitrogen
replenished we're going to sink this one
in and just let it run until it freezes
completely the battery is charged so we
shouldn't have any connection issues
with the battery and it's currently
recording so let's plunge this down into
liquid nitrogen and see what happens
Hero 5 session let's make it happen
look at how the nitrogen just bubbles on
the glass there I'm just going to leave
that there for a second because that's
kind of cool still recording so far and
all the way in cool now we're just going
to let that saute for about one and a
half to two minutes and when that stops
boiling the GoPro should be about the
same temperatures the liquid nitrogen
we're into at about 35 seconds now and
everything's going strong the picture
still looks clear on the bluetooth it's
actually amazing to me that it can still
transmit bluetooth wirelessly at those
temperatures it looks like it's starting
to glitch out a little bit oh yeah
camera just turned off at least it
disconnected from the phone but the
lights still flashing in there so it
looks like the GoPro is probably still
recording there's like some little black
junk floating around in there oh there
goes the GoPro just shut off so it looks
like these things can handle about 60
seconds in liquid nitrogen before they
automatically power down if you look
straight down on it it kind of looks
like a creepy eyeball this has been
sitting in there for about five minutes
let's go ahead and fish it out and take
a look at the damage there we go that
thing is cold watch closely what happens
when I breathe on it gently
you can literally see the moisture from
my breath condensing oh and it looks
like we lost the back panel. the back panel fell right off
oh and the buttons still
in there that right there is our button
so hopefully when that heats backup will
be able to pop that back together so
cool while that's thawing out let's go
ahead and torture test the hero five
black will leave this thing recording
until it shuts down all right let's go
for a nitrogen dip so far so good let's
give it about another five seconds here
oh look at that the crystals in the LCD
are actually freezing up see even though
I'm moving the camera around it's not
creating an image that is stationary so
we may have just fried the LCD we're
pushing 45 seconds now and I just heard
the camera shutting down it stopped
recording LCD screen is still on so
let's just go ahead and leave that and
see how long they'll sit before the LCD
screen shuts off again oh and check this
GoPro out this has just got completely
frosty what we've been waiting that's
insane frosty the GoPro ok so the LCD
screen has turned off again can I touch
it to make it come back on let's find
out ok it's gone completely unresponsive
and you see how that just frost over instantly
instantly the second it touches the air
all right so I think this one is cooked
let's go ahead and set that to the side
so there was a glass lens here and
that's popped off it looks like the
inner lens is still ok we may have to
fish off that glass lens let me grab
that really quick all right cool that's
really cold it looks like it was held on
with some kind of adhesive that probably
just got so cold and cracked away when
that warms up we may be able to just
push it back into place but you can see
this inner lens looks like it's probably
going to be just fine it was just this
protective lens that popped off right
now it's probably about minus 300
degrees Fahrenheit it's starting to warm
up just a little bit if we open the
battery compartment
her battery is still in there looks like
it's in pretty good shape oh okay so
that's not coming out I will just leave
that in there it seems that when the SD
card gets too cold the ejecting
mechanism doesn't work so we're gonna
have to let that warm back up and then
we'll see if we got any good footage
from it you can see the hero session
pops apart into three pieces we got the
button and the backplate and then we got
this little sensor this moisture sensor
it'll be interesting to see if that gets
triggered because it was just nitrogen
so it shouldn't do whatever it does when
i get stricken you can see those came
out pretty dang frosty will give those
about 25 minutes to warm back up and
then pull the SD cards and see if we can
recover any of that footage so update
guys it's a day later now and these
things have sat out all night and
completely acclimated back to room
temperature it took about an hour for
them to completely defrost and
unfortunately we lost all the data we
kept getting error messages saying the
SD cards were corrupted so none of the
footage that we got with the GoPros was
salvageable unfortunately so here's our
hero five black and here's our hero five
session so let's see if we can replace
the button and just pop that back panel
back in place so it looks like it's just
held on by adhesive nothing really snaps
into place there which is kind of
surprising so apparently we got that
adhesive so cold that it just froze up
and then when this metal panel shrunk
that's what caused it to pop off the
back so now that's warmed up hopefully
that will stay in place the LCD display
looks completely normal if we press the
button it looks like we can even get it
recording what's up welcome back from
your cryogenic bath so our hero five
sessions survived it looks like works in
perfect conditions so I'll probably be
using this for future videos let's check
out the hero five black and see how it
held up now the first damage we notice
obviously is this protective screen
popped off so it's obviously not
waterproof right now this Ridge right
here is tacky though and now that it's
warm back up we might be able to clean
that lens off clean this piece of glass
and put it back
together so let's find some microfiber
cloth and see if we can restore it to
its original condition I am curious to
know if the LCD screen survived because
when we were doing our test if it froze
the image and I almost look like it
destroyed it so it'll be interesting to
see if that comes back on so this
display I noticed that there is like a
small crack it look like a hair at first
but I think it actually is a crack and
there definitely is something in there
between the layers of the screen so
that's not optimal however if we can
turn this thing on okay actually the LCD
screen on the front is still working
that definitely is some kind of a
fracture or crack because I can see it
is raised up underneath the surface
there and there is some discoloration in
the screen it's still usable it's just
not perfect and we've got an SD card
error but look at this the LCD screen is
actually still working and apparently
it's working very well that's still in
really good condition this blows my mind
because that was frozen solid you guys
saw the image was not moving I'm really
impressed that that came back to such
clarity how cool this is cool the glass
didn't crack or anything so as long as
we can clean this up and put it back
together it should be in pretty good
shape all right that's looking good
in place and hopefully with a little bit
of pressure we can get that adhesive to
grab back on I wonder if this voids the
warranty cool the screen is replaced it
actually looks like it's back in there
nice and tight sweet so this is the hero
five black I just put a new SD card in
and it was working perfectly so there
you have it guys now you know what
happens when you soak a GoPro in liquid
nitrogen they are surprisingly resilient
I had no idea that they'd hold up that
well so I threw these things back in
their packaging and they're almost as
good as new they're fully functioning
they work great and so I'm going to pick
two of you and give these things away so
stick around and I'll tell you how you
can qualify here's how to win yourself
the GoPro go to Instagram calm / the
king of random and click to follow my
page for the next seven days i'll be
posting Instagram stories with bits of
code embedded into them so you'll need
to write down the code every day for the
next seven days and i'll post a link to
where you can submit your answer and
enter to win the gopro but remember
instagram stories only lasts for 24
hours you need to check in every day to
get the next piece of the code
instagram.com / the king of random
follow me there watch for the updates
and best of luck with the contest see ya